>> THE ACADEMY AWARDS HAVE
ANNOUNCED BY 2024, ALL FEATURE
FILMS WILL NEED TO MEET SEVERAL
DIVERSITY REQUIREMENTS IN ORDER
TO WIN BEST PICTURE.
TO SATISFY THE ACADEMY,
FILMMAKERS CAN HIRE AN
AFRICAN-AMERICAN OR NATIVE
AMERICAN FOR THE LEAD ACTOR OR
THEY CAN ENSURE THAT AT LEAST 30
COGNITIVE OR PHYSICAL
DISABILITIES.
MARK STEIN IS A LEGITIMATELY
SERIOUS STUDENT OF FILM.
WE THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
INTERESTING TO GET HIS TAKE ON
WHAT THIS MEANS FOR THE.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
>> THIS SEEMS LIKE A TURNING
POINT.
YOU THINK IT IS?
>> WE USED TO THE PONIES FOR
DOING THINGS LIKE THIS, MAKING
WHEN THEY SAID IN HUNGARY IN
1945 THE HUNGARIANS LEFT OTHER
OPERETTA.
THE MISFORTUNES TO SIT THROUGH
ONE CALLED THE STATE DEPARTMENT
STRUGGLED.
IT PLAYED ABOUT AS WELL AS IT
SOUNDED AND WE’D MADE JOKES
ABOUT THE COMMUNIST FOR DOING
THAT ALL THE WAY THROUGH TO THE
FALL OF THE BERLIN WALL AND
RIGHT AWAY DOING IT.
30 PERCENT OF SECONDARY ROLES
UNDER THIS NEW DEAL ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO BE FILLED BY MADE UP OF
PEOPLE FROM AT LEAST TWO
UNDERREPRESENTED RACIAL GROUPS.
FOR EXAMPLE YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE NEW AFRICAN BLACK
PANTHER MOVEMENT.
I WASN’T QUITE INTERESTED IN
MAKING ANNA FILM ABOUT THEM, BUT
YOU COULDN’T UNDER THESE RULES,
BECAUSE AT LEAST 30 PERCENT OF
THE SECONDARY ROLES WOULD HAVE
TO BE BLACK, AS WE’VE SEEN, THEY
KNEW AFRICAN BLACK PANTHER
MOVEMENT IS ENTIRELY WHITE, SO
THAT FILM COULD NEVER GET MADE
IN TODAY’S HOLLYWOOD WOULD.
THIS IS THE DEATH OF ARTS.
THIS IS ART BY QUOTA, AND THERE
IS NO FUTURE AND THAT.
THEY ARE DECLINING AS A MEDIUM
OF INTEREST.
CAN ANYBODY CREEK CREATIVE NOW?
>> CREATIVITY DEPENDS ON THE
TRUTH.
AND CREATIVITY IS IN DECLINE
OVER THE LAST 100 YEARS.
WE’VE LOST THE ABILITY TO DO
CERTAIN THINGS LIKE OPERA OR
REPRESENTATIVE OIL PAINTING, BUT
IT DOESN’T MATTER BECAUSE NOW
WE’VE GOT NEW THINGS LIKE POP
SONGS AND SITCOMS AND MOTION
PICTURES, AND WE CAN’T DO ANY OF
THOSE TWO.
HOLLYWOOD HAS BEEN PROPPED UP
FOR THE CENTURY BY MID- 20TH
CENTURY SUPERHEROES MOSTLY
CREATIVE AROUND 1964 BY STANLEY
AND JACK KIRBY.
BUT WHICH PEOPLE STILL GO TO CA
BECAUSE OF WHAT WAS DONE IN 1964
.
IN THE MIDDLE MIGHT LIKE JK
ROLLING WITH CURRY POWDER OR
JAMES BOND, THEY ARE DEAD
CREATIVELY.
IN THOSE GUYS, IF YOU RECALL A
FEW WEEKS AGO, THAT LED TO
MAGAZINE BY THE WRITERS LIKE JK
ROLLING, THE HANDMAID’S TALE,
AND ALL THE REST OF THEM, THEY
ARE SORT OF, WE’RE A BIT
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS CANCEL
CULTURE.
LISTEN, LISTEN, MARGARET ATWOOD,
YOU GUYS NEED TO I KNEW SOME OF
THESE PEOPLE, SOME OF THEM WERE
QUITE HELPFUL TO BE DURING MY
FREE-SPEECH BATTLES IN CANADA AT
DECADE AGO.
AND THEY DON’T REALIZE NOW THAT
THEY ARE IN THE CROSSHAIRS AND
THEY HAVE 5-10 YEARS TO TURN
THIS THING AROUND.
IF YOU DON’T WANT TO BE DOING
THE SOCIALIST DEPARTMENT STORE
OPERATIC, YOU GUYS HAVE GOT TO
SPEAK UP NOW BECAUSE THIS IS THE
DEATH OF ART.
>> IN A MOVEMENT THAT HATES ART
AND NATURE, THEY HATE BOTH OF
THOSE THINGS, IS A VERY DARK
MOVEMENT.
I THINK YOU ARE RIGHT TO FRAME
THIS IN THE TERMS IT DESERVES.